[Musica]
ogni volta devo partire dall'inizio ok
di percorrere tutte le strade
dell'infanzia della giovinezza della
maturità
scegliere che tempi usare se il passato
il presente e il futuro
per raccontare la storia di michele di
mio fratello michele e anche della mia
famiglia
e soprattutto per per difendere questa
storia affinché non venga mai più
distrutta il venga donata a tutti
molto importante che ho sceglie il tempo
giusto
mi chiamo marco scarponi vengo da
filottrano anzi da cantalupo di fiducia
è un piccolo paesino in collina qui tra
il monte conero il fan vicino un bar una
balera una fabbrica tessile
una chiesa una scuola dell'infanzia una
ventina di case alcune vecchie alcune
nuove ma soprattutto tanti tanti campi
coltivati fossi
qualche albero
e tanto cielo
sono cresciuto con mia sorella silvia la
più piccola e con michele il mezzano d
sono il più grande e poi con i cugini
vivevamo tutti insieme all'aria aperta
guardate a vista dai nonni perché i
nostri genitori lavoravano la nostra
famiglia di origine contadina e abbiamo
tutto il tempo per
percorrere in bicicletta per giocare a
calcio avevamo estate lunghissime
stavamo all'aria aperta
stavamo nel posto giusto al momento
giusto
i nostri genitori decisero a un certo
punto di farci fare anche uno sport
perché credevano che attraverso lo sport
potessimo crescere insieme agli altri
rispettandoci confrontandoci
condividendo regole e passioni tempi io
scelsi uno sport originalissimo
il calcio
anche mia sorella siete il calcio e
pensate arriverà a giocare in serie a
femminile da capitano o da capitan a
come si dice la capitana mio fratello
invece scelse il ciclismo su strada o
forse fu il ciclismo a scegliere lui
il giorno della sua prima comunione è il
mio padre di regalò una visita a cortona
bianchi e qualche giorno dopo si
iscrisse alla da nino pieralisi di jesi
una società ciclistica
inizia così il suo percorso sportivo in
sella a una bicicletta
farà tutte le categorie giovanili i
giovanissimi gli esordienti allievi
juniores correrà in tutti i paesi delle
marche perché una volta si correvano
ogni paesino delle marche dell'unghia
dell'abruzzo della toscana
vincerà tantissime coppie perché era
forte
un certo punto mia madre non sapendo più
mettere queste trofei inizierà a
regalare gli amici
e
era forte in salita diventerà uno
scalatore
perché lui sappiamo fare le salite
sappiamo farle con il sorriso
quando
entra nella categoria juniores vince una
gara importantissima pensate diventa
campione italiano su strada sacile in
friuli una zia giulia ed allora capimmo
che il suo sogno da bambino che era
quello di fare il giro d'italia si stava
trasformando in realtà
l'anno dopo diventerà dilettante partirà
dalle marche da vivere in veneto è la
prima volta per lui fuori di casa fanno
sport fa uno sport difficilissimo
durissimo come il ciclismo lo sport di
fatica pensate che i suoi petali e 18
anni andavano al mare a ballare ma c'è
una vita totalmente diversa dalla sua
lui deve stare attento a cosa mangiare
deve allenarsi con le testate
quindi ogni giorno vuole smettere fare
il ciclismo 18 anni una cosa durissima e
mio padre mia madre ogni sabato
partivano dalle marche per andare a
castelfranco veneto e stargli accanto
per degli michele noi ci siamo
fare la scelta giusta
noi ci siamo
e così mi che era superato i quattro
anni da dilettante ed è diventato
professionista
trasformato il suo sogno da bambino
nella professione è diventato un
ciclista professionista nel 2002 ha
iniziato a correre tutte queste cose
magnifiche il giro d'italia
il tour de france la vuelta di spagna la
liegi baston liegi la milano sanremo
la sua carriera da professionista stata
come si dice costellata di successi ma
anche di
insuccessi di scelte giuste di scelte
sbagliate
michele stato capitano di tante squadre
con cui ha corso è stato anche poi
gregario ha vinto un giro d'italia anzi
arrivò secondo perché il primo fu
squalificato per doping
poi vinse una tirreno adriatico
e alla fine della sua carriera appunto
trasformò in gregario vagare di vincenzo
nibali che è più grande ciclista ancora
attività che abbiamo in italia i tifosi
l'hanno soprannominato l'aquila di
filottrano per che
volava sulle cime alte e lui sapete cosa
ha fatto si è allenato una pappa galla
coloratissima una pappa galla re che si
chiama frankie che vola libera
un'aquilana pappagallo correrà sulle
strade di tutto il mondo
fino a quando
la mattina del
22 aprile il 2017 parte da casa per
allenarsi per partecipare al prossimo
giro d'italia
e a neanche due chilometri da casa
a filottrano nella sua filottrano un
uomo alla guida di un furgone decidi di
svoltare a sinistra
non lo vede e distratto
lo investe e uccide
quindi due secondi è finito tutto
c'è sempre cerri
botti
da quel giorno a casa c'è un buco
un grosso buco perché c'è un prima e un
dopo
e unire queste due fasi il prima e il
dopo quello che stiamo stiamo cercando
di fare ogni giorno ma difficile perché
il buco
non si copre con una doula con un altro
pavimento
non ci si riesce poi bisogna dirgli
intorno se ti affacci
inghiotte ecco è difficile vivere
appieno
perché a michele
dove michele
mi chiede non è morto sapete è stato
ucciso
è stato ucciso dalla violenza stradale
da una persona che
non ha rispettato certe regole della
strada e anche da quelli come me che
hanno avuto sempre una cultura sbagliata
della strada
e poi michele non era solo il ciclista
michele a rubare
i due bambini mi chiedono un figlio di
chiedere un fratello un amico
e michael era forte in salita
sapevo fare le salite
e noi dovevamo imparare a fare le salite
quindi con mia sorella ci siamo guardati
e abbiamo detto dobbiamo ripartire
ma come si fa
come si fa
abbiamo chiesto a michele michele ci ha
portato indietro al 2016 una tappa del
giro d'italia la terzultima tappa la più
dura da pinerolo si andava risulti
doveva scalare il colle dell'agnello
2744 metri
michele era il gregario di vincenzo
nibali che la terza in classifica
pronti via si parte michele scattava in
fuga stacca tutti arriva ai piedi del
colle dell'agnello e ora c'è la salita e
lui è forte in salita e inizia a salire
aumenta il vantaggio dagli inseguitori
ma intensa le rimane solo lui e
giganteschi muri di neve gelata al suo
fianco
arriva in cima che ha oltre 5 minuti di
vantaggio dal resto del gruppo ormai
fatta nessuno tecnicamente può più
raggiungerlo ha vinto quella tappa deve
solo scendere e poi fare una piccola
salita verso di sul ha vinto nessuno può
più raggiungerlo si butta in discesa
vincerà una tappa al giro d'italia dopo
sei anni vincere una tappa al giro
d'italia ragazzi è qualcosa di mitico
ma mentre fa questa discesa succede
qualcosa alle regolari profetici
cristiano gli auricolari per comunicare
con il ds con i compagni di squadra
viene avvisato che dietro la maglia rosa
un olandese era caduto è andata a
sbattere contro uno di questi muri di
neve ed era andato per terra si era
fatto male era risalito ma andava molto
piano e vincenzo nibali che accanto a
lui era terzo in classifica a quel punto
ha l'opportunità di attaccarlo e sfilati
la maglia rosa
ma per completare questa rincorsa ha
bisogno di un gregario un regalo che gli
si metta davanti e lo aiuti ad aumentare
l'andatura perché in due si va più forte
e quel gregario là davanti del michele
da michele viene chiesto michele fermati
che qui si vince il giro
mio fratello sta facendo la discesa è
dentro di lui si stava chiesto cosa
faccio mi fermo e aspetto vincenzo
oppure vado dritto vinco perché questa
tappa mela merito
michele si ferma si ferma staccato il
piede dal pedale ometto a terra e
aspetta aspetta si carica di borracce di
barrette aspetta
in quel momento sta realizzando una
una scena leggendaria del ciclismo
l'essenza del ciclismo
aspetta aspetta
poi quando arriva vincenzo io ti mette
davanti
e inizia a federale sempre lui e davanti
pedala pedala dà tutto quello che ha in
corpo aumenta il vantaggio dalla maglia
rosa
e quando non ce la fa più
si sposta vincenzo scatta e va a vincere
quella tappa e il giorno dopo grazie a
questa azione di michele prenderà la
maglia rosa e vincerà quel giro d'italia
quindi
che cosa ha fatto michele quel giorno
sapete nel ciclismo c'è un detto che
dice la maglia rosa non mette mai il
piede a terra perché chi mette il piede
a terra e chi non ce la fa più chi
rinuncia che getta la spugna invece
michele quel giorno ha messo il piede a
terra perché perché era più forte
e l'ha fatto per per aiutare un suo
compagno di squadra
michele quel giorno già segnato forse
che la vittoria più importante non è
la tua vittoria personale ma da vettore
ad un altro
la vittoria di un gruppo
e quindi
noi abbiamo capito grazie a michele che
il tempo da usare il presente
e il presente
e oggi intendiamo questo piede a terra
tutti dicendo
mette il piede a terra rallenta la
velocità uccide
metti piede a terra non usare il
cellulare quando sei alla guida
compie una strage
sei un assassino
mette per terra non bere alcol non fare
uso di prove
quando devi guidare
sei un complice
se un terrorista
mette il piede a terra usa la bicicletta
la nostra città ne ha tanto bisogno
possiamo curarla possiamo renderla
migliore
usa la bicicletta metti piede a terra
perché la strada è di tutti a partire
dalla più fragile
la strada è nostra
qualche mese dopo
la morte di michele
che è come dire è apparsa tra le mani
una poesia di un poeta turco di un
grande poeta turco nazim hikmet
e che da allora poi o come dire un po
inciso nella mia anima per non restare
più solo è smarrito controllo contro il
nulla
pensate un'apposita talmente banale e
vera che te che per capirla ho dovuto
aspettare
decisione di michele
vedono l'ultima l'ultima strofa
la vita non è uno scherzo prendila sul
serio
ma sul serio a tal punto che a 70 anni
ad esempio
piante rai degli olivi
non per lasciarli a dai figli
ma perché non crederai alla morte pur
temendo la
e la vita
peserà di più sulla bilancia
grazie
[Applauso]